今天开始第二阶段的课程。
咱们第一阶段讲的是故事，就是教大家写故事，先写出一个故事。然后第二阶段教大家把故事变成剧本。
因为故事是剧本的原材料呀。
先有故事，再有剧本。
然后怎么把故事变成剧本呢？是有步骤，有方法的。
也是咱们第二阶段需要解决的问题。我有教学计划。
但是今天呢咱们要打破一下这个教学计划。
加一节课。
佳节啥课呢？硬。
好多的同学强烈要求，不停的发私信给我要求。
让我讲一讲剧本的格式。
你说剧本的格式值得一讲吗？
可以讲也值得讲。
我为什么同意了这部分同学这个无理的要求呢？因为我之前讲过，我说我年轻的时候想当编剧的第一件事儿，就是想知道剧本的格式。因为我觉得我已经了然于胸了，有的是故事，给我个格式，我就往上卡就可以了，我就直接你给我个模子，我就生产了呀。
我当时就是这么想的。
所以我理解这部分同学呃，自认为天赋异禀。
然后按捺不住这种心情，今天咱就给大家讲一讲，早晚得讲。
然后呢嗯我也可以分享一份剧本给大家。像我当年那样照着一份剧本去看一看研究研究。
这个看这个视频的可以加咱的公众号，我把公众号打在这儿，加咱的公众号，咱们有学习小组，我会在里面分享呃剧本格式，找个好莱坞的得国奖的给你们行不行？
然后光看剧本呢，有些地方可能有点费解。咱们今天这节课就讲一下剧本的格式，提前讲一下吧。好吧，反正早晚得讲剧本的格式，剧本格式这种课咋讲呢？
这种课就有点枯燥了啊，讲格式。
一个剧本来说啊。
我们先看一份剧本，基本单位是场。
就一场一场戏嘛，这么理解好理解吧。那你写这一场一场戏都写啥呢？
首先，一个厂的描述分四个部分。
四部分。
首先是一个厂号。
然后是唐景。
然后是这个时间。
然后是内外。
就说你这一场戏基本单位是场，你这一场戏的第一行是这四个玩意儿。
唐浩呢很容易理解，就是你这是第几场戏了。假设这是剧本里面的第第17场了吧，那可能就写个017。
对吧你得留个三位数，留个三位数。我们说一般我们以电影为例啊，一个电影那怎么也得有个七八十场戏嘛，对吧？所以你留个三位数妥一点，万一干到三位数了，017。
场景是啥意思呢？场景就是。
你这场戏摄像机所能覆盖的范围。
比如说。
呃，这场戏是一个办公室，对吧？那就办公室办公室。
办公室啊，实7场办公室里的席时间。
啊，写一写几点吗？不是时间就四个字儿。
日夜成昏。
选一个就行了，就是这这场日戏还是夜戏，早晨的戏还是傍晚的戏。
咱们不需要具体到几点。
除非什么呢？除非你这戏里面有个关键的时间点。
呃，那你这场戏是会有具体时间的，有个炸弹什么的对吧？那平常来说就这四个字，好吧，日夜成昏内外。
哎，这更简单了，就是内景还是外景，就这二两个字2选一，内还是外。假设咱这个办公室系是个内系，内景系，对吧？内景系，那就写个内。
很容易理解是吧？这这这么说当然容易理解。
我们来说一下呃，具体的规则。
首先这个场号就是一几场。
一般来说，那你说这这是第十七场，那第十六场和第十八场他们之间的关系是什么？一般来说，换场的规则就是场景转换。
一般来说啊，换场的规则就是场景转换。
就以场景转换。
你就给他换场就完事儿。
一般来说。
然后第二个场景。
我们说结合第这个场景转换这个话题来。
办公室。
办公室的戏。
然后呢，我在办公室办公了。
接了个电话。
打这个电话了，打着打着就哎呀呀呀。
说到不便之处，有些事儿不想让别人听着。
然后就流的出去了。
我打着溜达出去了，假设我还没溜得远，我就直接这办公室有阳台，我就溜达到阳台去了。
那你看看。
那我第117场戏就又从场景到阳台了，我要不要换场？
我要不要换场？。
要不要换成第十八场？
这个呢。
看你爱好。
你他们爱换不换，没有那么重要。
你可以在场景里面写上这场戏，既是办公室，又是阳台。
就办公室和加阳台或者办公室加走廊，他还到走廊溜了一圈。
然后呢，把它归在十7场里面，也可以他。
去阳台那一段，你给他直接换场换了18场。
但有时候我不建议你这么切的这么密，为啥呢？你他在阳台说几句，他又回来说咋整，是不是？所以就这里呢就不用非去说这个场景一换了，你就给人换场了，这个没有必要。而且我再给你举一个例子，还有几段情况来。
第十七场，我们假设他没去阳台，就到办公室老老实实打电话。
但是来你打电话的对方，比如说你媳妇儿。
你媳妇儿在家。
然后有几个镜头切到你媳妇儿在家里坐在沙发上哎哎。
这是不是又一个场景啊，那你怎么办？
那肯定不能换场呀。你媳妇说一句，换下一场回来又你也有这一场，那就没有必要换。在这里场景呢显上办公室和家里沙发。
同一场戏，同一通电话嘛。
然后时间这里没有什么意义，日夜乾坤四选一。但是这个内外你看就出问题了。
办公室是内呀。
阳台室外。
对吧。
除非你这个阳台是蓬中阳台，你可以把它贵在内景。
就你你的摄影棚里面有搭过这个阳台，你特定的这个阳台，你可以把它归在内景。
如果是。
你没有这个阳台，你要去外面拍一个。
裸露的阳台。
那这里就是要有外景的。
你要写明白。
为什么为什么要专门写内外啊？我们说你看啊前面我们都很容易理解这场是到第几场了。我作为编剧，我应该。
写一下到第几场来这这场戏发生在哪儿，那我也得写一写这场戏的时间，那我是得写一写。那早晨和傍晚那肯定是两两回事儿嘛。
这个内外我为什么要写一下？
这是很重要的，为啥呢？这是你给灯光组一个准备。
因为所有的内景。
他都是可以靠灯光解决的。
就说这个办公室里。
他什么光都能给打出来。
他可以模拟，现在是个白天，模拟现在是个晚上都很容易，对吧？他在外面打个小太阳，你这里面就是白天。
他可以把窗都糊上，那这里面就是晚上。
包括你是内景的阳台，他也可以给你做出白天、晚上、阴天、下雨天，他什么时候就给你弄出来？
这就是内景。但是外景呢，你这场戏如果是个外景，你写了外了。
那么。
呃，这时候灯光组可能操的心就少一些了，但是呢外联制片组就操的心就多一点了。
因为你出真正的外景的时候，你是要吃天光的，就是你要靠天吃饭的。你这场戏对吧？你写了一个外，然后雨天。
好家伙，那今天没有雨，那大家得去准备水车呀。
是这么个意思。所以说你这个内外你也是要写明白的对吧？所以说一场一场戏先描述四样东西。
场号场景、时间内外好吧，这是基本的一个套路，是为了大家方便工作。
那么这场戏。
来。
来这场戏描述这四样东西之后，这假设这是第一行，对吧？那你第二行写什么呢？第二行一般来说写描述。
也就说这场戏这场戏里面。
包含的东西有描述。
行动。
和台词。
或者叫对白吧。
咱们专业语叫对白。
一般有这几样东西。
描述来第17场戏办公室里的。然后呢，现在是一场呃早晨的戏。
对吧然后内景。
描述。
那首先得描述一下这个办公室的样子吧。
的场景吧，比如说是早上的是一个忙碌的状态，对吧？忙碌的一个状态，然后有五六个员工分别在搞什么事情，然后穿着的风格是什么样的对吧？呃，有其中有一个在正在接电话，然后呢大声的冲对方嚷嚷。
旁边的一个人呢嫌他吵，但又没有。
吱声只是白了他一眼，你看这全部属于描述。
你得描述一下这个环境。
然后行动呢，比如说我们的。
我们说这个这个这场戏这个角色这个A吧。
A的电话响起A看了一眼来电。
号码呃，不想接放下，但是想了想，又拿了起来，看了看周围的人。
边接电话，边往阳台走。
就是A的动作，他的行动。
然后对白喂。
打电话给我干嘛？就是。
所以说一场戏眠包含。
这些内容描述。
行动。
对吧？
基本上是这么个规则。当然了啊，也有你看你说来咱们说比如说A。
他边往阳台走边接电话，这是他的行动。但是他在对白的时候，他有时候也会。
采取一些行动。这时候呢把一些简单的小行动，比如说点燃了一支烟什么呢，就在对白这里A，然后一般啊会。
打一个括号，比如说深吸了一口烟，然后又说了句什么。
就是说有一些简单行动也没必要说专门又分一行。
就打在括号里面也有这么写的，我到时候发格式给大家，大家自己去揣摩。其实啊这不是考试，没有人会盯着你必须怎么做，只是给演员，我跟你说剧本是什么玩意儿？
剧本是你给大家的一份工作参考，给各部门的一份工作参考。你要考虑到大家方便，你心里装置这件事情，你剧本就这个格式就会让所有人看得舒服，没有什么绝对的正确。当然了，还有啊比如说。
，行动这里一般人你看啊描述一行，行动一行，对白一行。
一般人会这个描述和行动。
符号。
对吧比如说描述这里他打个什么呃米字号，这个行动这里一般是打三角。
对吧当然有些人打实心，有些人打空心，有些人打正三角，有些人打倒三角。这根据每个学校不一样，每个老师不一样。
没有对错，因为你一打你就区分开了，别人就知道。还有一种啊还有一种剧本，就我给大家发好莱坞的剧本，你们能看到啊，他们喜欢把对白居中。
他们喜欢把对白居中。
呃，这些大家明白了吧？就是场景写四个东西，四要素，然后呢是描述行动对白。
大概是这么分的，当然还有对白完了又行动。
又对白啊，又描述呃，对吧。
都有。
然后我着重来说一下这个对白，好吧，我给大家讲一下这个对白对白呢，咱们咱们中国人的剧本里面，比如说这是一张A4纸。
来，我们假设这是一张A4纸啊呃假设这是你看顶头是017场戏呃，办公室。
然后早晨。
然后内景。
然后这是一行描述完了。然后第二行呃呃描述了一个米字号，描述了这个办公室的早上的忙碌。
哎呀，忙碌咋写来着？
刚才写过呢。
然后三角。
我们的角色A拿起电话。
走到阳台。
走出去对吧？然后呢，好莱坞剧本。
描述行动完了之后，他开始写剧本呃，他开始写对白的时候，这是第三行的时候，假设这个角色A，然后他就A。
然后再起一行叉叉叉叉叉叉嚓嚓接电话说你好。
然后呢，这个台词居中，而且说话的人和和这个说的台词他可以换行。
还得换行，但咱们中国人写剧本啊，就在这里就在这一行就直接A冒号，然后接他说就完事儿。
有很多人对这件事情有点费解，还老说哎啊，人家好莱坞这个格式比较比较先进。
嗯，肯定有它的好处。
但是咱们嗯会觉得这种写法比较费纸。
要废纸。
我给大家说一下，为什么好莱坞这么写啊，是因为他们剧本是用软件写出来。
他们软件里面有有自动的套用这个格式。
然后呃台词呢就给你做成居中。当然了，这样看起来是比较方便的。你如果光看台词全部带中间。
观看对白，全在中转。
人家为什么这个软件为什么这么写啊？是因为人家这个软件它一页只是一分钟。
这样让你便于计算。
你写了多少分钟的戏了？
然后嘞那你这比如说你这个你这一个很关键的一个事件，你想发生在本系的第45分钟，这样你可以明确的知道你现在就是在45分钟这一页，第45页嘛，就是第45分钟。所以他们好莱坞啊有个软件。
套着这个软件写就是这样一个格式，然后呢一页纸一分钟。
一也挤一分钟。
那咱们中中国有些编剧呢就模仿这种格式。
我觉得没有必要，呃，因为确实废纸确实浪费纸。而且呢你又做不到一夜一分钟，为啥？
你说为啥？
因为他们是用英语写的吗？他们是用英文写的，咱们是用中文写的。
咱们中文呢。
中文的音节效率。
比英文高。
能理解这个意思吗？
就说单位体积的中文表达的意思肯定是比英文要多的。所以你即便是这么写，你一页纸啊也在一分半到1分45秒。
左右。
你也不可能做到一页子一分钟。所以你既然失去这个这个计联意义了，你就你就没有必要模仿模仿他这个模式，就顶头写就完了，对吧？你只不过给你的描述和行动，前面做点符号，实在不行，你真的这个这个对白前面也做个符号，让大家区分的明确一点就行了。所以这个格式啊。
真的不需要去考虑那么多。说到这个音节效率啊，我给大家插一插几句啊，啥叫音节效率？就是你单位的音音节能表达的意思多。
就这个意思，或者说表达一个意思，咱用的音节少，他们英语用的音节多，这是啥区别啊？其实就是越古老的文明。
越大陆的文化。
它的音节效率越高。
比如说咱中国。
呃，这个文明史很长。
这个汉语文明时间很长啊。
咱们的音节效率就很高。
音乐效率高，有利有弊啊，这不是一个纯包义词。
随便说一个词儿啊。
比如说咱那个咱说咱那个那个剧本，一个想要殉职的警察警察。
对吧警察两个音节表达一个意思。但其实这个警察是日本。
传过来的这个词儿，对吧？
它相当于我们白化纹的时候，是相当于我们的白话纹。咱们这骨文比如说叫牙。
或者叫拆。
就一个音节，咱们如果用古文说这个咱们说拆这是个拆或者牙，就一个音节。
然后用白花文呢警查两个音节效率就低一点。两个音节表达一个意思。然后呢，你看英语please.
三个音件，咱们不说police买或者police officer，就police。
三个音节。
对吧英语音节效率就比咱再低一点。那你说如果南美洲、西班牙语pelic西亚四个音节。
表达这一个意思。
所以它就音节效率就偏低，然后它的篇幅就会大，篇幅大，表达意思小，表达意思少。
这是音节效率高，是咱们大大陆文明古老文明的一个优点。
那个所有音件效率啊就。
音节效率高的这些民族啊，唱歌就不行。
音乐都差点意思。
为啥？因为。
你就是说话表达意思太快了，你不需要唱歌。
啥意思？
你看日本日文日文的音节效率极低。
啊，我啊搁这干是呢，口对的，说半天。
表达一点点意思。
然后呢，它音节音节就多，音节一多呢，它就容易哎那呀个呀，它就容易唱起歌来了。
所以你看有句话说嘛，说中国有56个民族，55个能歌善舞，啥意思？就是越少数民族，他他越能歌善舞，就是因为他音节效率低，就比如说。
呃，壮族呀，或者是那些少数民族他为什么呃爱唱歌？
因为他们的词儿少吧。
音节效率低，就说明他们的词少。
同音词多，比如说。
呃，一个壮族。
农家一个女孩，她爹在山上那耕地，她想把叫他爹回来吃饭。
假设是个咱是个汉族，用汉语聊这个事儿，就说爸回来吃饭解决了完事了，爸就听见了，哎回来了就完事了，对吧？但是少数民族语言父亲有可能和太阳。
是同一个词儿。
很有可能父亲跟太阳在很多语言里面是同一个词，对吧？
然后呢，父亲。
跟大公鸡有可能也是同一个词儿。
对吧。
父亲跟大山也有可能是同一个词。
然后呢，他就说。
爸回来吃饭吧。
他爸还在那耕地呢，他以为你叫大公鸡呢，或者是叫太阳。
所以你得你得前面描述。
你就不能说单纯的说爸回来吃饭。
你得说。
挥舞着双手，正在劳动的我慈祥的父亲啊。
你得加各种定语才能区分开。
你如果只说强壮的父亲啊。
强壮的父亲有可能同时表达。
炙热的太阳。
是吧父亲跟太阳是同义词呀，所以他说强壮的父亲啊回来吃饭呀。然后你爹呢听到是你你说太阳很炙热，你有病吧，爹对吧？他不回来，所以你必须这一套词。
对吧。
呃，这个正在半山腰挥动着双手。
辛勤劳动的我慈祥的父亲呀。
快迈开你的步伐，矫健的步伐，回到我们温暖的家园，吃一碗香喷喷的饭吧。他这句话就得这么表达。
这么长的一段话，他不由自主的他就唱起歌来了。
所以所以你看少数民族为什么载歌载舞的？就是因为他们呃语言音节效率。
比。
古老文明要低一点，因为古老文明这个文明时间太长了，他已经把词儿啊，他这些词细化的。
爹回来吃饭，毫无意义毫无意义。
他就他就应接效率就低了。
我们说你看咱们汉人的歌，咱们这个中国汉语的歌曲跟那个那个那个其他二的文明的歌曲差距很大。咱们的写歌的水平确实挺差。日本为什么作曲那么牛逼？就是因为他音阶效率极低。
日本的歌一听就知道哪些是日本的歌儿，举几个例子啊，你看。
这首歌刘若英那首很爱很爱你哼，这首歌绝对是日语。
我不知道是不是啊，但我感觉是。
为啥你看他效率多低呀，哒哒哒哒哒才表达了一个他爱你。
然后呢，他为了这个一看这翻译成汉语之后有点单薄，然后他就重复很爱很爱你。
这典型的不是咱们汉人写的歌，汉人就中国人写的歌，你去看看，你去看中国人写歌比较有代表性的的这个李李宗盛、罗大佑、崔健他们那写的歌，我跟你说。
他们那一首歌恨不得这800字1000字，你知道吧？为你我用了半年的积蓄漂洋过海的来看你。
就这么一句词儿。
就这么一曲一句词，拍成戏的拍15分钟，为你我用了半年的积蓄，漂洋过海的来看你这个效率之高啊，就这么一一句歌词，效率极其高，表达了无数多的意思。但这这个旋律，如果谱上日文词，可能就是表达了一句我想你我真的很想你。
就是这就是音节效率的差距。
回到咱这个剧本啊，我就想说什么呢？咱没必要去说远了是吧？咱回到这个剧本啊，回到这个剧本。
就是什么意思呢？咱没必要去模仿好莱坞的模式，咱就用咱的模式。咱的模式呢一页纸啊，你如果用小四字体，其实字体也没有严格的规定。一般来说用小四是为什么啊呃是因为再小的话呢，老演员看不清了。
他们必须得在。
自己再单独打一套剧本，老演员一套，年轻人一套，很多剧组老演员一套剧本，年轻人一套剧本，所以字也不能再小了。一般来说这个这个字号的话。
按照这种格式写一页纸。
大家看也看编剧习惯啊，有些编剧废话多。
所以呢一般来说你看一个一部电影，假设这电影。
2个小时。
两个小时的话。
那就是120分钟。
八九十页八九十页是，当然我们不一定非按页数去去去理解这个事儿啊。按字数的话，我们算300字1分钟吧，我们可以这么算。
因为正常语速一秒钟说五六个字。假设你的剧本全是台词，一分钟的话，那就是300多个字儿吧。
300多个字儿。
所以你按一分钟300来个字儿去折350个字，比如你去折也可以。当然你剧本不是全是台词，但是你的描述不也是要拍出来的嘛？早上这个这个这个这个办公室如何的忙碌，他俩在争吵，他在偷偷干什么，他他在扫地，你这些描述他也要拍。
拍出来拍出来它也是耗时长的。所以一般来说按照。
一分钟算他350次。
按次算也行。
然后按场算的话，一一般来说啊，如果是电影一部电影。
120分钟的话，那可能是。
七八十场戏，就说你这个厂。
七八十场八九十场都有可能看你这个这个分的细不细碎。
所以说这些东西啊这个格式这个东西啊。
它只是一个方便。
统一一下格式，方便一下大家工作，方便一下各部门开展工作。
当然你可以有你的习惯，包括你包括分场，他就有有有一些很浓重的个人习惯在里面，对吧？包括描述。
一般来说是这样。
当然啊那你看我写剧本的过程中，当然也遇到过一些特殊的情况。你一行字人家得拍哎七八分钟，当然有可能了。比如说追车戏，你作为编剧来，你写头文字低，一场追车山间追车戏，你再怎么描述。
你也描述不清楚。
你只能把这么说吧，比如说你说呃呃这个主角角色A可能先占优势，然后呃压制了角色B。然后后来呢角色B反超，然后角色A呢又气急败坏，使了个阴章，你这些可以描述一下，但是像这种。
呃，追逐戏打斗戏。
这种戏呢可能是。
最终。
呈现主要是靠。
导演组。
所用组。
长景组。
他们能找到什么样的场景？
来如何呈现这场戏，根据实际的情况。
他们决定的比较多。
所以在这种戏就很容易出现你写了一行字，他们拍了5分钟这种情况，大漠孤烟，万马奔腾，8个字要他们的命，对吧？看起来在你剧本上就8个字，但是呢他们要搞他们要拍拍蛮久的，一会有这种情况都不绝对。
好吧，但是咱们呃编剧来说啊，写剧本的时候也要装着一颗拍摄的心，你少写点大漠孤烟万马奔腾这种事情是吧？真的剧情需要没办法。
所以说这个剧本啊的格式我就给大家这么简单说一下。
大家理解这个意思，其实就是剧本呈现给大家的基本单位是场，一共有多少场戏？
嗯，一般那就是电视剧的话，以及4445分钟的电视剧，那就是三十几场戏。
电影的话也是七八市场，八个市场，对吧？11一个电影的剧本。
四丸字。
看你描述的细致程度嘛。
但是这个东西还是在实战中，大家自己去摸索吧。我只给大家讲一个最基本的，好吧，这节课加出来的，我会分享一份剧本给大家。
好，下课。